so now have you had enough kids
i ain't in mexico yet so you know she's
not having another one bro it's it's
wild because the age gap yeah i
literally keep starting over my oldest
is 17 my newest is one and a half
wow so i have this wide range and i have
a beautiful four year old and uh 10 year
old and it's the greatest thing in my
life but
it is a wide range of humans you know i
have every age it's like how's um
like like your relationship is it's
crazy to see your instagram like like
you're all dressed up like are you going
to church on sunday like you're dressed
up like that like i i love church man i
do i've
i've found so much joy and peace and
just hoping my life through it it really
has helped me a lot
and i i didn't grow up without it i
watched my mom and dad
become part of it kind of in their 30s
40s and i watched them
quit drinking quit smoking
and i watched them kind of
just be a good example maybe it was
church maybe it was just them aging
but i remember thinking like i really
want that for my children and my life
and uh
just going to a little church here and
there and uh man it really connected
with me i fell in love with it man
that's cool that's epic dude i fell in
love with it and uh
just had some weird things happen in my
life that maybe some would just consider
coincidence but i feel it's just pure
blessing man like really the hand of god
oh well dude
like don't like yeah
i feel very strongly in
activity behind the curtain love it to
which we are not privy and how the
universe is
genuinely conspiring there's something
going on
the hand of god something 100 the hand
of god and and like i would you know we
could talk about this on on your podcast
but
i i
religiously meditate
for i maintain an average of over 40
minutes every single day meditating for
over 930 straight days oh wow yeah
that's beautiful man i spent like 600
hours meditating since uh 2019. what do
you do when you meditate is it it's
mantra it's a very uh quiet silence
you're working right
i mean
like uh
it's mantra based so like that same as
like a transcendental meditation
vedic meditation and uh and and i i'm
terrified of ever not doing it
interesting because i genuinely believe
that
that it it has uh formed a relationship
with the universe i am plugged in to
some type of other power and [ __ ] an
intelligent [ __ ] order of the
universe that is conspiring in my favor
i love it man i
i think that we all find things in in
you know as
man you know
there's just times where you just
shouldn't be alive
oh yeah you have survived there is
somebody watching over here
so man i love hearing that that's cool
yeah i have strong spiritual beliefs man
i have an unshakable faith and and i
genuinely believe that
whether it's going to church whether
it's meditating whether it's just like
being mindful to not do harm and to be a
generous human being a good human that
that brings about
like
some kind of respect for
the universe for for life for
you know being thankful yeah like like
like
that that's
a really big [ __ ] thing that's what
we're here for you know
i think that clip was awesome but not as
awesome as my new book a hard kick in
the nuts what i've learned from a
lifetime of terrible decisions which is
out september 27th and if you pre-order
it right now you can get the autographed
copy so get on it man pre-order my book
it's not going to waste your time
because i'm proven dude new york times
bestseller my first books five star
rated on amazon and i have no doubt this
one will be two so get the autographed
copy right now
by pre-ordering it at stevo.com
yeah dude